all righty so here we are in another ben
shapiro show facebook live special with
our good friend Adam Carolla Adam of
course if you don't know him it's
because you're ignorant but he's the
host of the incredibly popular Adam
Carolla Show
he's also three times New York Times
bestselling author his books are
hysterically funny and he is again
teaming up with my other friend Dennis
Prager on Wednesday November 29th at the
King's Theatre in Brooklyn New York for
an evening with Adam Carolla and Dennis
Prager and they're gonna talk about
everything from politics to life to
pizza toppings apparently and if you've
never been to one of Adams and in
Dennis's events I've been to one of them
and that they're really fun and
enjoyable Adam thanks for joining me
here so aside from a raking in some
extra cash why you do these events with
Dennis uh you know I love being up on
stage but I I like doing different
things and working with different people
and I've always been a fan of Dennis and
you know I we we come from completely
different worlds but I used to like
listening to him when he did religion on
the line a million years ago
and I'm not religious at all so I was
always a fan of his of course he had no
idea who I was cuz you know he doesn't
know who Janis Joplin is he doesn't know
he probably doesn't know Henry Ford like
there's nobody who knows less in terms
of pop-culture references celebrities
and especially see celebrities like
myself so he had no idea who I was but
eventually his producer or I think his
engineer made him aware of me we were
thick as thieves as soon as we got along
because even though we're totally
different we both agree on common sense
and I think if you can agree on common
sense its trumps everything
you can break down everything you know
abortion gun control you you know build
a wall whatever it is about yours
whatever topics if if you are very tuned
into common sense and you're tuned in a
common sense and fraggers tuned into
comes you'll agree on 98% of the subject
because if common sense prevails you're
not
gonna land on another side of the topic
so we're million miles apart except for
the common sense but that always brings
us together I mean you guys you guys got
along so well that I know you're doing
documentary together too about what's
going on on the college campuses I was
lucky enough to meet up with some of
your guys when who came along with me to
the to the Berkeley insanity but how's
the documentary going when is that
supposed to come out it's gonna be mid
early 2018 it's going very well it was a
perfect time to make this they just came
to me and said you want to be part of
this you want to work with Dennis and
you know any excuse to work with Dennis
so we are following people like you
we're talking to college professors were
following ourselves out on stage we're
gonna do recreations it's not gonna be
just a straight-ahead documentary it's
gonna be a little more of a film with
young Dennis and young Adam and and all
that kind of insanity so I think it'll
be very compelling it'll always be funny
it'll be interesting and hopefully it'll
make you think and entertain awesome
well Adam if you missed it you can also
go watch Adam testify in front of
Congress I had to play second fiddle to
Adam testifying in front of Congress
about about bias on college campuses you
never want to sit next to a comedian
during a congressional hearing it's
always a mistake but that was those sort
of my lot in life anyway I will say
about that you don't want to sit next to
an A student during pass either
especially the one where you can't cheat
off of because I had that feeling about
you two which is
I'm a horrible student always was a
horrible student and probably got my
improv chops through being horrible
students and learning how to wing it so
to speak just sort of make it up on the
fly and I flew in late to Washington the
night before you know slept till 5:30 in
the morning got up had no idea what I
was gonna say and then I saw Ben Shapiro
a students with his six pages you know
fifty one seconds of stage totaling out
five minutes and I think what have I got
myself into because I had a No
had it's an arrows leading to the ideas
like oh I want to say this idea after
this idea but it's ahead of it on the
page I'll draw an arrow that'll remind
me to say it later well it's a I do have
to ask a dimeric are you doing any
college appearances because I know that
you know every time I do a college
appearance now I have to have these
massive security teams have you actually
done any events at colleges in the
recent past are you planning to it's so
funny that you brought that up because I
just found an old page on it that I can
hold up from from June of 1998 this is
me and dr. drew and it's us at Northern
Illinois in DeKalb University of Texas
University of Wisconsin University of
Wisconsin Whitewater University at
Savannah Kansas Florida clams in Kansas
again Alabama this is all in the course
of like five weeks we played like 19
colleges laughs we would teen Lee toured
the country and tour colleges and I
think those days are over
it was no big look back then you just
show up with your opinion say whatever
you wanted on stage just get paid and
leave yeah I mean it so so are you gonna
do any more colleges who've been invited
GG I just avoiding them at this point
I'm not I'm not invited to play any
colleges and I think those those days
are over
I mean quite honestly I don't even know
what I would want to tell a 19 year old
anymore III mean I know it's prestigious
and I and I know you can also make some
money doing it but to sit there and have
to endure that and hassle it and deal
with the security and the safety and
then whatever I mean we're living in a
super weird world right now right like I
just had the conversation with my wife
20 minutes ago where she explained in LA
there's supposed to be some big and Tifa
rally or attack or whatever it was you
know this weekend and I said well I'm
due to go to the convention center
to do a I'm gonna interview Sylvester
Stalone I'm gonna do a talk on
podcasting - like the wealth and real
estate Expo or whatever and then I was
invited to go to the Lakers game
and I want to bring my son with me to
the Lakers game and she said I don't
want him going downtown during this and
Tifa rally and I thought well first off
this is never gonna happen but on the
other hand why does my wife and my son's
life have to be ruined by this like just
like just the idea that I'm saying to my
wife in 2017 hey good news I got seats
on the floor someone gave me tickets to
see the Lakers game this weekend and she
goes hold on there's an antifa rally I
don't know
she didn't say I don't want you going
well I mean I assume that she inherits
in your will so it's probably okay if
you go and you get killed by an tyfa you
know she lives on but right yeah you put
your hair don't forget your make America
great again but my son is gonna have to
run serpentine from the the car into the
Staples Center and I just thought what
the hell's going on with our society's
it is it is totally nuts I mean I you
know you've seen some of it I've
obviously been at the center of some of
this stuff and and it is crazy how much
people are willing to lend credence to
these people especially I was reading a
book today though that was sent to me
reviewing it for a commentary magazine
about you know the rise of anti-semitism
in the United States and I'm not a big
believer that there's been like some
tremendous rise that Jews have to live
in fear I mean you know me I wear my
yarmulke everywhere whether or not I'm
on TV or not you know like I'm walking
around the streets in my annika I've
never felt unsafe and in Los Angeles
wearing a yarmulke I mean half the
city's Jewish but one of the this book
does this whole routine about how the
real problem with the rise of
anti-semitism is people giving too much
credence to free speech if only they
would just stop with all this free
speech nonsense then we could really you
know sort of in a common-sense way
regulate the sort of speech that that
people are allowed to say and then they
wonder why people are rioting when when
I go to speak places I mean it's it's
it's total craziness and you're
- I mean I don't know a lot of people
who are more moderate on politics than
you are especially cuz you're not coming
from a place where you're deeply
concerned with political matters of the
day more than stuff that just sort of
pisses you off but if you went on a
college campus now I mean what you're
saying is right you get protested there
would be people outside calling you a
racist people calling you a homophobe
and and you'd have to wear you'd have to
wear Kevlar I mean I have it a couple of
campuses the thing I don't get is guys
like the aforementioned Dennis Prager
are called anti-semantic I mean if you
want to it is insane to me that we are
now living in a time where like the
number one Jew and the United States
Dennis Prager who just returned from
Israel he's when he goes to do a college
key part of amongst the things they call
him
they include anti-semites like at this
point we we are completely jumped the
shark like I don't even know what to
believe and and also you know for those
who are accusing everyone of everything
be careful because it's completely lost
its its teeth there is you know there is
no more I don't know who the actual
racists are anymore because everyone's a
racist and as I always say he's never
been a better time to be an actual
racist you'll get lumped in with me and
Dennis Prager and Ben Shapiro yeah
exactly exactly I mean if you're calling
Dennis an anti-semite I mean he's
literally the biggest you I know like
physically the biggest you I know so
that that is that is not that that is
not correct well Adam he's gonna be host
a Adam Carolla's gonna be hosting with
Dennis Prager an evening with Adam
Carolla and Dennis Prager aptly named
Wednesday November 29th at the King's
theater in Brooklyn New York did you
know when the tickets go on sale how
many seats there are what the cost is on
that stuff they're on sale now and
they're probably like a two or three
thousand seat bed that's a big venue
they're on now and just this put a fine
point on dennis prager being the biggest
Jew literally if you were making a Jew
smoothie and you put him in a blender
you would have a grande tallboy juice
smoothie when that that you'd be like a
medium you know medium small post direct
potent but still medium he would be the
biggest tumbler of jus that ever came
out of a blender and I'm definitely
looking forward to all the alt-right
websites now photoshopping memes of me
in a blender after this particular
conversations folks if you don't listen
to the show you're really missing out
Adams fantastic and it has been forever
and as I told him before we went on air
Adams an inspiration to people like me
because Adams the guy who who realized
that you could actually create pirate
ships outside of the normal radio
channels in order to actually distribute
your content to people who want to
listen so Adam Carolla institution in
the industry go check it out and evening
with Adam Carlin dennis prager november
29th at the King's Theatre in Brooklyn
New York
Adam and also quick quick question is
there a website that people should go to
to get the tickets or is it like
Ticketmaster dot-com hit live events
perfect okay go and check it out Adam
Carolla thanks so much for joining me
here on the bench Shapiro show Facebook
live YouTube live good to see you dude
thanks man judge Amit